قريبا نطوي صفحه عاما ونبدا عاما جديدا
والتوقعات والتقارير حول وضع العام الجديد
بدات ومخيا يبدو ان الاتي اعظم فاذا شعرتم
بموجه حار شديده خلال هذا العام او حتى في
العوام السابقه فانتم على وشك استقبال ما
يوصف اكثر حراره بحسب توقعات مكتب الارصاد
الجويه في المملكه المتحده العام المقبل
سيكون واحدا من اكثر الاعوام سخونه على
الاطلاق تتوقعوا الارصاد ان تكون متوسطه
الحراره العالميه اعلى بنحو 1.2 درجه
مئويه من ما كانت عليه في اوقات ما قبل
الثوره الصناعيه واذا صدقت التوقعات
فسيكون هذا هو العام العاشر الذي يصل فيه
متوسط درجات الحراره العالميه الى درجه
مئويه واحده على الاقل فوق ما كان عليه في
فتره ما قبل الثوره الصناعيه بين عامين
1850 و2900 فما استمراريه زياده انبعاثات
الغازات في عالميا على من المحتمل ان يكون
العام المقبل عاما بارزا اخر في سلسله
اكثر الاعوام سخونه على مستوى العالم
[موسيقى]
بحسب السجلات الحاليه يعد عام 2016 اكثر
الاعوام حراره على الاطلاق وهو العام الذي
شهد علامه مناخ النيل وفي المحيط الهادي
وتسبب هذه الظاهره المعقده في ارتفاع
درجات الحراره في جميع انحاء العالم
وصنفت المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه
عام 2019 كفاني اكثر الاعوام حراره منذ
بدا تسجيل البيانات الدوليه بدرجات
الحراره كم متوسط درجه الحراره العالميه
الثانويه كان اكثر ارتفاعا مقدار واحد
فاصل واحد درجه مئويه عن المتوسط في
الفتره ما قبل الثوره الصناعيه وبدا عام
2020 من حيث تتوقف من عام 2019 ليكون ايضا
من اكثر الاعوام حراره مع الارتفاع
القياسي لحراره المحيط واحداث مناخيه ذات
تاثير ضخم شهده ذلك العام وبحسب المنظمه
العالميه التابعه للامم المتحده فانا
متوسط درجات الحراره لفتره 5 سنوات من
2015 الى 2019 كانت الاعلى على الاطلاق
والقادمه
[موسيقى]
سيكون اكثر سخونه انت مع الجو البارد ولا
الحاره انا حاليا انا حاليا بعيش حاله
نوستالجيا للجو البارد يعني لما كنت هيك
اطلع من الشباك واشوف الثلج يتساقط وقاعده
هيك انا بس هذه حاله انستالجه مشتاقه لها
طقس البارد
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير لك صباح الخير لجميع المشاهدين
في ارجاء الوطن العربي
والعالم في الحقيقه تتاثر الكره الارضيه
حاليا في ما يعرف بظاهره الميناء وهي
انخفاض درجه حراره سطح المياه المحيط
الهادئ عن معداتها الطبيعيه الاعتياديه
وذلك له تاثيرات حول العالم هذه التاثيرات
تتراوح ما بين ارتفاع وانخفاض في درجات
الحراره بشكل كبير عن المعدلات طبعا
بالنسبه للكره الارضيه بشكل عام هو هنالك
نسق تصاعدي في درجات الحراره في الملاحظه
بالسنوات الماضيه سنوات الحاليه والمستقبل
هنالك نسقط تصاعدي لارتفاع درجه حراره
الكره الارضيه ككل في النصف الشمالي
لكن في في خلال هذا السياق تلاحظ بعض
المناطق انخفاضا حادا بالحاره مثلا
العاصمه البريطانيه لندن شهدت خلال
الاسبوع الماضي يتساقطا الثلوج على عده
ايام ايضا جليد هذا غير معتاد في العاصمه
البريطانيه لند حيث تاثر بريطانيا عاده
بتيار الخليج الدافئ والذي يسبب ارتفاع
الحراره
وليس بطريقه علميه علينا كاسراد مثلا انا
اعيش في بلد تصل درجه الحراره فيه الى 48
في الصيف عندما تصبح زياده درجه ثانيه
يعني تصير 49 كيف ستؤثر وكيف سيتاثر
المجتمع حولي
لا الموضوع مو هيك هو ارتفاع درجه حراره
الكره الارضيه في مناطق ستشهد ارتفاع
مناطق تشهد انخفاض مثلا بريطانيا معتدين
الحاره في لندن بتحكي عن خمس او ست درجات
مئويه بالشتاء كانت الاسبوع الماضي ناقص
خمسه كان كل يوم الصبح في عندنا جليد في
لندن زلاقات في عندنا حوادث في ان تاخيرات
هذا المعدل هو معدل الكره الارضيه ككل ففي
مناطق راح تشهد ارتفاع عن الحراره
الطبيعيه لكن درجه حراره الكره الارضيه
ككل نعم هي في ارتفاع منذ الخمسينات يعني
منذ 50 سنه ماضيه هنالك ارتفاع تدريج سنوي
في درجه حراره الارض هذا مرده في بشكل عام
الى عده نظريات ربما غازات
مناخيه حدثت في المنطقه تحدث في المستقبل
لكن نصق هو النسق تصاعدي حول الكره
الارضيه بشكل عام لكن المناطق معينه
استشهد ارتفاع وانخفاض جميل مناطق معينه
هل هناك مناطق معينه انت ستكون اكثر سخونه
وماذا عن منطقه العربيه ما هي المناطق
التي
قرر بتغير المناخ
على سبيل المثال القاره الاوروبيه الاسبوع
الماضي كانت درجه الحراره فيها منخفضه جدا
على المعدلات متوقع ان تشهد ارتفاعا عن
المعادلات خلال الاسبوعين القادمين الرد
حاره الى حد ما معتدله متوقعه في القاره
الاوروبيه على العكس في مناطق في روسيا
ووسط اسيا منطقه همم ربما العراق ايران
وسط اسيا كذلك الحارس تشهد انخفاضا الحاره
وذلك ايضا في الطريق نحو الجزيره العربيه
استشهد المنطقه خلال شهر يناير القادم
شهرا بارد ربما درجه حراره دون المعدلات
في هذه المناطق كلها والقاره الاوروبيه
على العكس ترتفع فيها الحاره عن المعدلات
خلافا للفتره الماضيه مثلا القاره
الامريكيه الشماليه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه شهدت انخفاضا كبيرا على الحاره
خلال الفتره الماضيه يتوقع ان ترتفع خلال
الشهر القادم عن المعدلات لكن هذا النسق
هو النسق معتاد كل سنه بارتفاعه انخفاض
لكن ترند او نسق الكره الارضيه العام في
الارتفاع منذ اخر 50 سنه نظرا لعده نظري
ايمن ومن بين هذا النظريات نتائج التغير
المناخ التي بدا التعصب في بناء لكن ماذا
علينا ان نفعل نحن كفراد يعني هناك تقليل
من اهميه مساله الاهتمام بالبيئه والمناخ
ويعني كافراد نتحدث وهناك نوعا ما استهزاء
من الاخرين الذين يركزون على مساله البيئه
ومساله الطقس وحمايه الطقس حمايه هذا
الكوكب ماذا علينا ان نفعل
للاسف طالما حدث هذا الاستهزاء على الاقل
على مستوى الافراد لكن الدول العالميه
الصناعيه الكبرى حول العالم تعقد عده
مؤتمرات سواء في فارس سواء في تركيا سواء
في اوسلو في واشنطن دي سي خلال على مر
السنين الطويله الماضيه تعقد مؤتمرات
سنويه وفصليه حول التغير المناخي هنالك
كما نرى نظرات جديه من الدول الصناعيه
الكبرى حول العالم لتخفيف منبعاث غازات
الدفيئه نحو الغلاف الجوي وهذا فقط من
خلاله عده نتائج مؤتمرات حول العالم
همم ربما في دول العالم الثالث او بالعالم
العربي على الاقل ان تتوجه الحكومه حول
الطاقه البديله الطاقه المتجدده مثلا
الطاقه الكهربائيه في المركبات بعيدا عن
البنزين او الديزل ربما هذا يخفف من
الانبعاث الحراري من الدول العربيه صوبه
اداره الجوي لكن بطبيعه الحال هذا النسبه
الاكبر هي من الدول الصناعيه الكبرى حول
العالم
مها روسيا الاتحاديه الصين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه القاره الاوروبيه
العجوز هذه الدول جميعها حاليا متوقع
معاهدات اتفاقيات للتخفيف من هذه من غازات
الدفيئه وفعلا نجحت في العديد منها في
التخفيف من هذه القراءات اول اكسيد
الكربون ثاني اكسيد الكربون اكسيد الكبريت
نجحت بالفعل خلال سنوات الماضيه بالتخفيف
وستنجح بالمستقبل وان شاء الله اذا كانت
نظريه التغير المناخي مرددها الى غازات
الدقيقه سوف نحصل على نتيجه جيده ان شاء
الله خلال 20 ربما 30 40 سنه القادمه لكن
اذا كانت تغير المناخي ليس بسبب فقط
التغيرات الدفيئه انما دورات مناخيه
ستستمر التغيرات على وجه الكره الارضيه
بالحدوث ان شاء الله
دكتور حراره هذا الارض ترتفع بارتفاع
سخونه حراره الاحداث في العالم للمفارقه
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور ايمن خليل مناخ
المستشار في شركه طقس العرب